incompréhension des français colère des
politiques certains en tout cas qui
s'inquiète d'une possible restriction de
liberté avec l'idée d'un passeport
sanitaires dont notre question de ce
soir la dictature sanitaire est elle en
marche c'est l'objet de notre face à
face et pour en débattre nous sommes
nous avec marc de lattes député la
république en marche de l'aisne bonsoir
marc delattre merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés jean lain la capelle député
européen du rassemblement national
bonsoir vous aussi journalières d'aqap l
âge merci d'être là c'est donc un marine
le pen qui a sonné la charge la première
contre ce projet de loi instituant un
régime pérenne d urgence sanitaire je
vous propose de regarder ce tweet de la
patronne du rassemblement national avant
de vous faire réagir
jamais nous n'accepterons que le
gouvernement impose par la coercition ce
qui n'a pas été capable de faire
accepter par la confiance il ne peut y
avoir de citoyenneté de seconde zone
pour les individus non vaccinés c'est
profondément délétère et liberticide une
liberticide
d'ordinaire c'est un mot utilisez plutôt
par les élus d'extrême gauche est-ce
qu'il n'y va pas est ce qu elle n'y va
pas un petit peu fort marine le pen
journal à capelle non je crois qu'elle a
tout à fait raison
vous savez il m'a lu macron le premier
ministre le ministre la santé au lieu
vers on nous avait promis qu'il n'y
aurait aucune vaccination obligatoire et
qu'il laisserait aux français la liberté
de ce choix est bien en effet grâce à
marine le pen notamment
nous constatons dans un projet de loi
qu'une petite mesure parfaitement enrobé
comme le disait votre confrère tout à
l'heure et bien vise à contraindre à
conditionner toute la vie sociale des
français s'ils sont ou non vacciner
eh bien je crois que si dans la forme
c'est honteux dans le fond c'est en
effet liberticide et
anticonstitutionnelle d'ailleurs et
c'est une forme de dictature comme vous
le formuler dans votre question je crois
qu'en effet le gouvernement aujourd'hui
n'a pas compris que les français sont à
bout ils ont été disciplinés pendant des
mois et des mois ils ont dit oui
confinement ils ont dit oui au
couvre-feu
ils ont dit oui au protocole sanitaire
ils ont dit
il ya tout ce qu'on leur impose et et
demain et le gouvernement n'a pas trouvé
mieux que de vouloir restreindre encore
plus les libertés individuelles
ça s'appelle de la ségrégation je crois
que si le gouvernement souhaite que les
français il se vacciner et bien qu'il
rétablisse un climat de confiance
c'est la voix de la sagesse alors à tort
ou à raison en tout cas il ya eu un
hashtag un pas seulement des politiques
mais de plusieurs milliers d'internautes
cet après-midi intitulé dictature
sanitaire d'où notre question un peu
provocante marc delanne c'est bien la
scène dictature sanitaire qui est en
marche
bah écoutez moi je suis député mais je
suis aussi médecin je peux vous dire que
je n'ai pas l'impression de vivre dans
une dictature sanitaire loin de là et il
faut savoir que ce projet de loi qui est
une a et qui institue un gym pérenne de
gestion des yeux carte sanitaire ni
s'inscrit finalement dans ta processus
de l'état de droit c'est il est lié du
fait de la carte du sexy si vous voulez
et du comme il exprime d'abord actions à
l'étranger ou en france du projet du
cadre des législatives de mars dernier
un grand état de droit il est normal
nous établissons ce rappel n'a donc eu
sur ce que je pense et du projet de loi
pour l'état sanitaire d'un côté et
d'urgence sanitaire et il faut une
réelle l'articulation entre les deux
îles et il est normal aussi de donner
des moyens de l'état de droit au niveau
des parlementaires en mission avec eux
mais mes collègues d'achat ollier et
sont estompées pour justement mettre des
ddd car il n'est pas question de le
produire notre de passe-temps
obligatoire le grain l'île d'er d'abord
ces vaccinations gratuites 1
elle est volontaire et non obligatoire
et 5
plus que la lave à ce disparaît du jour
au lendemain
jean françois delfraissy au conseil
scientifique a bien signifié qu on
aurait au moins jusqu'au mois de juin
donc à choisir le vaccin steen ont
empêché les complications av
je rappelle qu'il ya quand même un taux
de létalité de plus de 8% chez les gens
de 80% de 80 ans donc il est français le
comprennent tout à fait qu'il ait pris
le lin la limitation des flux à porter
ses fruits on le voit d'ailleurs en
suède où ils avaient tablé sur une
immunité collective
ils en viennent aux mêmes mesures que
nous préconisons en france et donc on
fait pas partie des mauvais de l'europe
après je veux pas dire faire cocorico
parce qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
troisième vague de plus je crois que
c'est une situation de responsabilité et
de donner les moyens en droit au premier
ministre de faire en sorte que nous
perdons pas de réactivité
lorsqu'il ya une crise et ça c'est
important voilà marque de la tête pour
l'instant on a on a perdu jean jean
naslin capelle c'est pour ça que je
voulais c'est pour suivre vos idées je
crois qu'il ne nous est pas entendu on
va poursuivre tous les deux comment tout
de même vous expliquer ce scepticisme
des français inquiète beaucoup plus
important la france qui est l'un des
quatre pays les plus sceptiques un quant
à ce vaccin
il va bien falloir convaincre d'une
manière ou d'une autre vous en convenez
de cela bientôt h de l'ifop fin novembre
qui signifie 41% des français se ferait
vacciner
ce qui est important c'est que ce vaccin
si vous voulez nous puisse toucher au
moins 60% de la population pour aller
vers une immunité collective de ce fait
si vous voulez en plus il ya une
sécurisation industriels puisque les
vaccins je le rappelle nous serons
produits notamment sur nos sites de
production en heure et en indre et loire
quoi qu'il en soit mais preiser bien sûr
seront les premiers vaccins et ce
scepticisme si vous voulez
l'un de vos interlocuteurs rappeler une
citation de jean paul sartre la
confiance la confiance et se gagne pas
une information claire lisible simple et
compréhensible et répéter si vous voulez
donc dans la loi il ne faut pas perdre
la réactivité et la réactivité elle ne
peut pas une figé et donc ça passe par
un système de décret voit dans toutes
les crises épidémique
alors concernant les vaccins
obligatoires bien sûr la fièvre jaune si
vous allez en nous dans certaines
parties de l'afrique le vaccin
obligatoire
là il n'est pas question du point de vue
des engagements du président de la
république et je penserai objectif de
rendre un vaccin obligatoire
ça repose sur une sur une acceptation
volontaire mais à condition justement
que cette confiance passe aussi par une
information et un consentement éclairé
voilà et c'est le cas par exemple dans
les ehpad moi qui suis au conseil
consultatif national d'éthique nous
avons rendu une opinion au premier
ministre au nom de nathan a récupéré
avec bonheur on l'espère en tout cas
gens là la capelle la première phrase
j'ai eu la chance oui vous avez entendu
la première phrase
et bien voilà on a reperdu décidément
gens là la capelle le pourcentage de
vaccinations nécessaires pour atteindre
une immunité collective un marc de
lattes varie selon le virus pour le coc
vite 19 il est estimé autour de 70 %
sans certitude toutefois
justement cela nous inquiète en tant que
député en tant que médecin aussi que ces
français n'aillent pas se faire vacciner
justement si on les force pas puisque
vous n'êtes pas si j'ai bien compris
pour la vaccination obligatoire vous non
plus non alors que moi je n'ai il faut
pas forcer les gens à se vacciner il
faut pas non plus les culpabiliser parce
qu'il ne se vaccinent rompt pas ah on
peut le comprendre d'ailleurs si vous
voulez la notion de liberté en fait tout
ça ça nous dit sur notre société
d'accepter des contraintes au profit du
collectif et il ya toujours un phenom ii
tensions entre l'individu et le
collectif
bien sûr si je suis jeune est ce que
finalement projets moins de 30 ans est
ce que je vais développer une forme
sévère vraisemblablement pas mais au
delà de 40 ans et les le risque augmente
et les orages site owni cytokines il si
vous voulez où il ya une destruction du
tissu pulmonaire à au dixième jour
fatalement va sur sur la létalité 1 et
donc si vous voulez l'acceptation avait
aussi générationnel de ses libertés
je regarde une émission très
intéressante sur père de qui parlait de
cette fameuse bible dont contenant 1969
où l'information est et était moindre et
il n'y pas tout commence et c'est l'une
de deux observations épidémiologiques
aujourd'hui on est beaucoup mieux
informés on est parfois sûr informés et
ce point de défiance il va jusqu'à avoir
une défiance sur les sur le la parole
médical c'est pour ça que le comité
scientifique dont s'est doté le
président de la république est
absolument indispensable et jusqu'à
maintenant ils ne se sont pas trompés en
explicitant qui auraient une deuxième
vague courant octobre et puis peut-être
une troisième donc ces mesures
que nous prenons sur le projet de loi
elles sont justement pour encadrer et
facile et la réactivité de notre réponse
aux crises épidémique face aussi aux
systèmes d'urgence sanitaire c'est cette
loi les fait aussi pour comment dirais
je
comment faciliter cette articulation
entre crises sanitaires et urgences
sanitaires
voilà donc ce etc c'est tout simplement
la section 2 de l'article 1er est donc
en france on a toujours l'habitude ci
comprend un petit morceau de la loi et
tout de suite on le met en exergue et
tout de suite avec des cris d'orfraie
sagaie la liberté est entachée etc non
je pense que la protection des français
et des foncières sont mais moi je leur
dis au jour d'aujourd'hui ils en sont
pleinement conscients je pense que
maintenant vous hydrate dans leurs
familles et ils sont conscients des
mesures que nous prenons
merci en tout cas marc delas 12 étiez là
justement pour défendre ce projet de loi
face à jean laquelle la capelle qui est
plutôt contre ce projet de loi mais
qu'on a perdu en cours de route vous
excuser en tout cas pour ce problème de
réseau chargé ce soir merci à vous deux
messieurs